well good morning ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to the August meeting of
Bama and mid suffix joint overview and
scrutiny committee there's a hammer here
which I have to
apparently gavel but I've never been
happy with banging things so we'll just
move straight on item 1 on today's
agenda is apologies and substitutes
Henriette good morning oh yes we have
received apologies from councilor scarf
and councillor Otten is substituting for
councillor scarf okay I turn to
declaration of interests councillor
mother could you use your microphone
please counselor mother I'm a member of
the trustee board further mid stuff at C
IV so non pecuniary interest counselor
Osborn Thank You mr. chairman yes I am
an observer at sudbury CA
and obviously I'm known to Colleen who
is the chief executive thank you also
not the carry interest I believe anybody
else at Council area
Thank You chairman I also know I
remember but I represents every town
council at CA B and well but number
theory thank you very much all three of
you
item 3 on the Yemen and agenda is Jos 99
to correct the table paper here it is
not the meeting held on the 18th of
August but that of July this was a joint
meeting and you have those minutes in
front of you
[Applause]
it's like a friend confronted me at the
moment I hear their mr. taebel phone
isn't it yep the table favorite there's
the table paper page 1 page 2 page 3
[Music]
page 4 page 5 page 6 page 7 our members
satisfied that that's a true accurate
record of the minutes of those meetings
councilor Osborne proposed adoption
seconder councillor Muller and all those
in favor it's fast and then we now come
to the confirmation of minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of June BOS 19
stroke 5 this being for labor of
district council so only babe remembers
will be able to vote upon these so BOS
19 5 page 1 page 2 page 3 and finally
page 4 okay so every member of Baberaham
there's a true and accurate member
record of the minutes okay can I have a
proposal from the Baber of councillor
Aires seconded by councillor Brandon all
those in favor from Weber okay item 5 on
the agenda is confirmation of minutes
held on the 27th of June not July as it
states on the paper but in paid minutes
themselves are correct regrets what
we're going to decide actually so MOS 19
stroke 5 I should ask Council well them
to do this but since I'm just here
already will carry on obviously it'll
only be mid Suffolk members voting upon
these page 5 on the paper which is page
1 of the minutes page 6 of the paper
which is page 2 of the minutes page 7
page 3 and page 8 the final page the
fourth page of those minutes as
everybody from mid Suffolk satisfied
that that's a true and
your record of those minutes could I
have a proposer from the mid Suffolk
members councillor Whelan's
seconded by Councillor Mullah mid stuff
at members in favor and that's carried
thank you very much members item six is
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme and received you item seven
questions by the public
none received and item eight questions
by councillors none received chair all
right so we move on to the first terms
of the substantial substantive item on
the agenda which is on the Citizens
Advice bureaux z-- presentation I do
actually just realize that I've
completely missed out a introduction for
the public meeting in the council
chamber for the chair so keen was like
to get moving on so my apologies to you
and members of the public and thank
heavens a fire didn't break out in the
course of the last few minutes some
domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room up as
it stairs cold water is available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town football training pitch do not use
the atrium stairs to exit the building
and do not re-enter the building until
you are told it is safe to do so
if we could all switch off our mobile
phones or turn them to silent that would
be great that gratefully accepted I'd
just like to remind everybody present
the meeting is being broadcast live on
the internet or if they're foreseen was
a complete mess I've made of the
beginning of chairing this meeting the
whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting you will
be deemed by the council to have
consented to being filmed by entering
this room you are also consenting to
being filmed by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and/or
training purposes the council members of
the public and the press may record film
photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded finally camembert's and
officers please ensure that you press
the microphone for speaking and turn off
when you've finished so we come to item
9 which is what reminded me about this
red paper I had in front of me and I
think I'd like to introduce it by my
Coleen Sweeney the chief officer for
Sudbury and district Citizens Advice
bureaux and Carol Eagles the manager for
the Citizens Advice mid Suffolk based I
think at Stowe market who will provide a
presentation for an about the Citizens
Advice bureaux can I hand over to you
two ladies thank you very much for
inviting us today I'm Carol and this is
Colleen and and we would welcome all of
you to visit us at our respective LCAs
and also appreciate the opportunity to
come to talk to your for council as well
as and invite all the councillors to
visit as in the and communities
sorry sorry about that right okay so
[Applause]
technology is sorted let's carry on yeah
thank you very much okay so Citizens
Advice we are there to give provide free
independent confidential and impartial
advice to everybody we try to provide a
holistic service where we look at all
the issues that are affecting a person
rather than just their presenting
problem because somebody might come to
us with an issue with you know
relationships and that then might lead
to dirt housing domestic violence so we
deal with the whole situation and we
have very much a needs-based approach we
look at the needs of the client and then
give them the support that they need
and to help them to deal with that
problem and we try to empower people so
we don't take the problem away from them
if we think that they have the abilities
to deal with it themselves and they just
need pointing in the right direction
then that's the support that we give or
if they need extra support and
encouragement and we'll provide that on
an ongoing basis so we don't have a
limit on the amount of time that people
can have if they need just one
interaction that's fine but if they need
ongoing support over a year two years
three years we carry on doing that for
as long as it's required so we're part
of the local National Citizens Advice
but we are separate entities in our own
right and Sudbury is celebrating 50
years of service of delivering the
service this year and in mid StuffIt
we've been delivering for 38 years so
between us we've got 88 years of
experience of delivering advice and
support in our local communities so we
understand the needs of our communities
and how best we can deliver that service
being part of Citizens Advice also has
its advantages we're a recognized brand
that people trust we are provided with
procedures and policies which allow us
to be cost effective because we don't
have to reinvent the wheel and we are
audited on an annual basis by Citizens
Advice to ensure that the quality of
is correct the organizations are
well-run they're financially stable and
that gives us the advice quality
standard and we're also regulated with
by the financial conduct authority so
though we don't provide financial advice
as such as to where to invest your money
we do provide debt and money advice so
last year we provided help to over 6,000
people in beta and mid Suffolk and
people can access help and support five
days a week across the district they can
get advice by phone face-to-face or
email and we understand that as a very
rural community the phone advice is key
to the kind of service that we're
offering because not everybody can get
into an Sudbury or Stowe market for
advice and we know the rural transport
system is not brilliant in our district
so phone advice is really key so of the
contacts that we do about 40% of them
are face to face and about 40% of them
are people phoning up for help and
support and then about sort of the
remaining sort of email and letter so we
do email advice as well and then as part
of one of our new services that we're
offering which is the help to claim for
people claiming universal credit we are
trialing web chats and that's quite
useful for us to see whether there's a
avenue for that sorry this question
hmm are your appoint are your calls and
visits all pointment based or can
someone you know if someone might have
an urgent problem can they call you and
be dealt with that day or do you have to
or do you say Oh we'll call you back in
two days time how does it work please if
somebody phones up then we try and deal
with their problem there and then
because they may be phoning because they
cannot get into stone market or
submarine or wherever we're delivering
an outreach so it's important to us that
if it's an issue that we can deal with
over the phone then we will deal with it
there and then if we think it's taking
long longer for us to research the issue
then we will phone people back because
we recognize the fact that if you're
calling from a mobile phone that might
be costing people money so we will phone
them back and the drop in people can't
just drop in without an appointment and
in fact we offer both things so people
can drop in and get full advice there
and then but then they might come in and
they've got an issue that they haven't
bought their paperwork for in which case
we'll make them an appointment to come
back with their paperwork so they can do
that if we're completing benefit
application forms for them for
Disability Living Allowance for children
or personal independence payments or
something like that then we will arrange
an appointment for them to see a person
that would help them fill in that form
because that will take several hours
so wherever possible we give them the
advice straight or start to give them
the advice straight away okay so we also
offer advice from outreach locations
such as GP surgeries or we've done and
joint visits for instance just to Donna
Barnes
we went together with the counselor -
stolen bonds we've been to we went to
Seven Sisters when they were an issue
there and so if there is an area where
something is happening but it needs a
little bit of support then we will do
that as well so advise issues when I
started doing this role 10 years ago
debt was by far our biggest issue and
then the debt and benefits were sort of
side by side and our benefits far
outweighed eggs and we the universal
credit is obviously the new benefit for
people in work and looking for work but
we are still getting the same demand for
help and support with the legacy
benefits by legacy benefits I mean
Employment Support Allowance of personal
independence payments so more the
sickness benefits and we've got a
particular issue at the moment that we
are getting a lot of people being
migrated from the old benefit disability
living allowance to personal
independence payments and they have the
DWP have really pushed through the
numbers and that is being quite
difficult for us and the LCAs across the
county to manage that demand so we've
had to put extra hours and support in to
be able to deliver that and then the
results that were getting from those
applications quite often they're not
quite where we would expect them to be
and the clients would want them to be so
we're then having to ask the decisions
to be looked at again and the appeals so
it's not just the initial application it
has an impact all the way through and so
which is why some people need lots of
ongoing help with each stage of the
process employment housing and
relationships and family they're our
next issue biggest issues and as I said
earlier if you get a relationship
situation the chances are you will get
you are going to get
housing possibly debt and benefits all
part of that that need okay so the bulk
of our service is delivered by
volunteers and our volunteers we've
worked out using a formula developed by
Citizens Advice that between labor and
myths offer cows volunteers general if
we paid them the normal going rate we
would have to pay six hundred and fifty
over six hundred fifty seven thousand
pounds so we'd have to triple our income
if we had if we paid all our volunteers
to deliver the service for us and that
service is supported by the equivalent
of nine point seven full-time paid staff
and most of that the paid staff our time
is spent on supervising and managing the
volunteers because without volunteers
need training they need support they
need encouragement and so and their
quality of their work checked so where a
client needs extra help in benefits as I
was saying just now or they need help
with their money advice I need
bankruptcy advice or debt relief orders
or we have somebody with employment
issues then we will support people with
Appeals and we will help represent them
at tribunals and that is done by our
specialists and our trustee boards they
are selected from the local community
and they are all volunteers and all our
volunteers are locally based for wanting
to help our local communities and give
back okay so we work with partners we
try to have a collaborative approach so
we do referrals to the food bank with
one of the referring food banks referral
agencies and we use a whole host of food
that's across the two districts and we
can also access charitable support so
that charitable support could be for a
washing machine
or to get a cooker repaired it could be
in the past we've got grants for twins
that were going to college and needed
Astro boots each because they were doing
a sports course we've had grants for
debt relief order fees or a huge range
of hairdressing equipment you name it
we've managed to get grants for it and
we also work with other providers so we
work with shelter for housing advice and
we'd work with Age UK Suffolk family
carers lots of other local charities and
national charities and one of our most
important partners other councils Baber
and myth Suffolk District Council and we
work closely with the housing team so
where we will go and look at people that
are about to be made homeless and
support them with their work we will
also do joint visits where benefits are
concerned and clients need to support
with benefits but they can't come to the
bureau and we've also as I said earlier
we've done joint visits to Stoneham
barns so we see the councillors one of
our key partners and then in addition to
our core services we also have project
funding for specific projects so
National Citizens Advice has got pension
wise which is advice for people that are
nearing retirement and are considering
what to do with their pensions and we
have services and we have those
appointments delivered in our local LCAs
and last year
Sudbury had 147 of those appointments
and in mid Suffolk we had 137 we also
provide energy advice and that could be
supporting people to sort their energy
suppliers or energy say
leaving you know loft installation
things like that or grants to fix
boilers and between us we dealt with
over 200 clients last year and then we
both have family law clinics where Bates
well as important we come in and deliver
and in Sudbury you've got quite a few
solicitors that will go in and provide a
free half hours to clients that have got
matrimonial issues you know access to
children divorce and that and then in
miss Suffolk we have a project
specifically for families affected by
multiple cirrhosis where we give support
to mainly benefit form-filling for
families affected by MS and then in
Baber
and Submarine districts are just about
to start the social prescribing the
health to connect in partnership with
suffer family carers and they will be
delivering an advice aport in build
Aston and Hadley and surgeries so that's
a bit of a whirlwind from me but the
last thing I wanted to mention was the
paving slabs which are probably familiar
to you from your strategic plan so he
picks out the three paving slabs that we
think are key to the work that we
deliver because when we develop our own
business plans it's important for us to
help you to deliver it your strategic
priorities and in fact the County
Council strategic priorities as well so
the three that we've picked out our
housing because we feel that we support
the councillors with their homeless
prevention strategy the top three
priorities for housing being the
prevention of homelessness supporting
vulnerable households to secure and
maintain accommodation and mitigating
kin
the impacts of welfare reforms so by
providing income maximization and
helping people through the benefits and
helping people with their rent arrears
you know not paying their rent or is
obviously but freeing up their income
and increasing income
and looking at their outgoings we can
make people more able to pay their
council tax and their rent whether they
be Housing Council has tenants or social
or private and tenants and then the
asset is the asset side we deal with
neighborhood disputes and help people to
move to more suitable accommodation
because there may be debts on a property
that's preventing the moving and we will
help them to resolve those issues and
then from the strong and healthy
communities there may be a reason why
people are not engaging with their
community and that could be lack of
money and that could be because they're
not getting all the benefits that
they're entitled to and they cannot
afford to go to the WI because they
can't afford to make the donation for
their cup of tea or they can't afford to
go to knit and natter because they can't
afford to buy the world or good quality
incontinence pads or there could be a
whole host of issues which is keeping
somebody in their home and not engaging
in their local community and so by
providing them with holistic advice and
managing their issues affecting the
health and well-being we can release
them space to go out and engage in the
local community
so there's a fair bit about what we do
so should we have a look at the results
in the past year we assisted clients in
gaining welfare benefits of 1.4 million
in with mid Suffolk and 230,000 in
Sudbury and district we managed debt at
1.3 million in mid Suffolk and seven
hundred and one thousand pounds in
Sudbury
I'm sure it's of interest to you to know
that after credit card and mail order
debts the highest amounts owed were for
council tax debt and Housing Benefit
overpayments both in 1718 and 1819 many
of the people who we helped reclaim
welfare benefits are disabled and
therefore at risk in terms of their
vulnerability by helping these people to
get a secure income we enable this
underrepresented group to be active in
their communities our work contributes
towards the wild countywide anti-poverty
strategy to improve financial inclusion
in the districts we directly support
those readers residents who may find
themselves in financial difficulties our
debt management work with clients
includes interventions that have been
shown to work
we offer free and impartial debt advice
we can help people to access appropriate
debt solutions as a route into debt
relief we increase the uptake of
means-tested in and out of work benefits
we also improve the financial knowledge
and skills of people who need our help
so that they are better equipped to
manage their income so our work with
people in debts is also preventive and
helps people to sustain a good financial
position in the longer term
[Applause]
National Citizens Advice use the model
that is approved by the Treasury - now
down the figures for the financial
impact that we have these figures are
local to Citizens Advice in Suffolk and
are produced by the team at national
Citizens Advice and who work on the
model so for every 1 pound invested in
the Citizens Advice service in Suffolk
national government and local
authorities save three pounds 52 pence
for every one pounds invested in the
Citizens Advice service we generated 20
pounds 84 pence in wider economic and
social benefits for society so looking
at Suffolk as a whole this meant that we
saved the national and local government
8.1 million pounds and we generated
wider social and economic benefits of 48
point 1 million pounds to be honest
nobody comes to volunteer with Citizens
Advice because they want to save
national and local government money
we're here because we know that people
face problems and think that they should
have good advice to help them deal with
those problems at the same time these
figures can show a helpful way of
communicating the impact of that support
on the wider community we help councils
to deliver their statutory duties if we
can step in and stop a person's problems
from escalating then they don't end up
homeless
they don't default on their council tax
they can stay and work they don't get in
to rent arrears
we have a regular client survey that is
sent out after an appointment to ask
clients for their feedback this is
administered by National Citizens Advice
and is standard practice across the
citizens device Network the survey is
sent by text message or email and these
are the results the results are very
similar across both LCAs 77% of our
clients said that the service had to
help them to find a way forward whilst
94% said they would recommend our
service it's our focus on quality advice
that has led to these results and we're
really committed to keeping the focus on
quality advice going forward research in
campaigns used to be known as social
policy is the side of our work that
isn't so well recognized but is equally
as important on local national scale
there are some problems that we have
beyond our ability to solve to be honest
and this is where our research and
campaigning comes in no one else sees so
many people with so many different kinds
of problems and that gives us a unique
insight into the challenges that people
face today we collect some monitor
evidence on the problems that people
face and we use that evidence to
campaign for change and some examples of
where we have our universal credit
bailiff protocol private renters rights
ng bastille payday loans scam awareness
and welfare reforms this is another
example of how we seek to prevent
problems in the first place
so what the challenges in September we
are celebrating 80 years of Citizens
Advice nationally the service was first
established at the start of World War
two to help people to adapt to the
challenges they faced we are locally
funded independent charities we do not
receive core funding from National
Citizens Advice it's thanks to the
support of our local funders that we are
able to offer our services our main
funders are Baby amid stuff at district
councils so thank you to review for your
support
when Suffolk County Council announced
that they were going to have and then
withdraw their funding the local
Clinical Commissioning group used some
of their contingency funds to make up
half of the funding that we received
from the County Council we are very
grateful to hear that they will provide
half of the amount of funding again in
2020 and 21 we've worked hard to
diversify our funding in recent years
and we are fortunate to have the support
of a range of local Charitable Trusts
and community groups for example Stowe
Market relief trust the Ganz only trust
the outfit that sorry Alfred Williams
and Jeffrey Burton trust some of our
providers provide money sorry some of
our funders provide money for specific
projects which cannot be used for call
funding such as Multiple Sclerosis
Society who fund a worker to give
dedicated support to people with MS the
outlook generally is that it is very
challenging to secure sources of funding
that are sustainable there simply aren't
many options for us to fund the core
running costs of keeping our offices
open and at the same time we're seeing
an increased demand for our services the
introduction of Universal Credit has
been the biggest change in the benefits
system
since its introduction and although we
have a project to help people making new
claims it can be a complicated benefit
to claim and we do anticipate that
people will still need advice in the
claiming process in addition our
populations are aging and more people
are experiencing frailty and loneliness
we expect to see an increased need for
advice from the elderly people in our
districts another factor that has
increased demand is the reduction in
voluntary sector provision generally for
example the closure of opera and Age UK
suffixes in tour for advice we have
become the main organizations for the
completion of benefit forms along with
all else we do one of the things that
makes us anxious is that the average
level of household debt is that pretty
much the same level that our debt
clients so so any economic shocks such
as an increase in interest rates could
weld lead to an increase in demand for a
Money Advice services another challenge
we face on national trends that have
made it more difficult for us to recruit
volunteers such as the increase in the
retirement age and the increase in
mothers in paid employment locally we've
heard some rumors around the future of
Citizens Advice across Suffolk and
although we have tried carefully to get
the message across about the impact of
how the withdrawal of the county
council's funds has had an inventory has
had to challenge on recruiting
volunteers it seems that there are
expectations that the loss of the county
council funds will render all of some of
the Suffolk LCAs as unsustainable and
this could have put people off from
joining us this isn't in fact in reality
we will feel the pain but I have through
careful strategic planning being able to
diversify our services to find ways to
weather the storm
having said that for mid Suffolk and
Baber LCAs
we are now even more reliant on the
funding that we have from our District
Council's our core funds ensure that we
can attract funds from other sources but
there is a lump a limit to what we can
bring in as project work without
saturating our capacity by taking time
and resources away from the delivery of
the crucial work that we do in our
general advice services we aim higher to
deliver the service that we aspire to
and for that reason wood asked you all
to consider very carefully that it is so
important for us to plan our future
strategy in line with our three-year
business plan
[Applause]
thank you all for inviting us and taken
an interest I do hope that they we have
been able to give you a good insight
into the services of both LCAs but
please to ask any questions that the
presentations left unanswered thank you
both Carol and Colleen and I think the
slogan at the end there for everyone for
80 years as a rather proud boast that
many organizations will be very pleased
to be able to make I'd like a point of
clarification on one thing that Colleen
you said towards the end of the
presentation that a clinical care
Commission board are going to provide
half the funding that they have done
this year that's in 1920 now as I recall
Suffolk County Council withdrew we're
going to supply half last year or this
apparent high and reducing to nothing in
2021 in this case with the clinical care
commissioning board be taking on the
position that Suffolk County Council
were prepared to do last year in other
words will you only get half the money
you would have got and that you're
getting this year so there is a
shortfall there yeah so very fortunate
to have half in the park for 2021 from
the CCG talks are still ongoing with
Kam's council so we're not feeling that
solder lost yet we're still you know
harboring hopes that they will see the
the good sense in continuing and with
the support of the CCG will have halved
their bill so yeah but that was really
good news that's that's giving us a lot
of reassurance and we hope to work with
the CCG well into the future
Mikki know exactly how much that is the
amount of money that you will lose or
suffolk CA B's will lose for Supreme
Citizens Advice it's around about
without avenues that figure in my head
it's around about twenty five thousand
pounds to half of the county council's
funds or just under I was going to say
that there are there are some figures
contained in a couple of infographics
that were supplied to members of the
committee but not everybody able to
message necessarily and we do have the
last time dot for count 1718 if anyone
would like a copy I'd like to throw this
open to members questions on earth
opposed to those Carol and Colleen
councillor Grandin thank you Kevin guess
we all very much value the work Citizens
Advice does um we've talked about the
need for funding I presume your funding
goes towards rental of offices and so on
but your volunteers could you to explain
how the funding is used what kind of
thing you need the money for if you're
mostly volunteers please we have travel
expenses which we cover we obviously
we're obligated to ensure that no
volunteer is out of pocket by come in
and giving their time to us we also
cover extensive training so that they
manage their supervised by paid staff
they're heavily supervised as Carol
explained earlier it's part of the way
the service works the trainings ongoing
of the nature of the advice that they
give there's always changes in
regulations legislation they need to be
updated constantly about new benefits
that have come in so there's always CPD
training going on which we have to
either provide ourselves at a cost of a
training officer or usually and that's
outside of down to our local offices so
we pay quite large amounts for any
training courses that people go on we
tried to cover things like team meetings
away days events where because a lot of
our people were all of our people though
did they mainly come in on one day a
week the advisors all mostly people
whichever role they advise in they don't
tend to see each other through the week
so we tried to people come for two
reasons they come because they're
usually people who have had very large
background careers and want to give
something back and also for the social
contact with like-minded people who also
want to give something back but it's
nice to be able to provide the odd
social or training event as a large
group in which case we have to provide
those catering venue costs so there's
all sorts of expenses really but I
suppose one of the biggest ones would be
the supervision and the management of
them can often
okay I don't think I need to declare an
interest being a county counselor any
particular reason why you should care
and really you know it's not something
you need to sound guilty over obviously
I was obviously present when obviously a
lot of this information came forward so
my questions would be one of the
arguments was that given that the level
of reserves that the DA B's had and
obviously we would like to hear from you
why we felt that that was a cogent
argument and the other thing is
obviously we were delighted and I'm sure
everyone here was that there was this
last-minute reprieve but obviously it
would be interesting to know at what
stage Suffolk CA B's had a conversation
with the districts and the County
Council in order to be able to have
avoided that crisis the other thing is I
know that a lot of problems come about
about you know particular scams etc and
how much do you work with Trading
Standards because I know they're very
active in certainly particular telephone
scams where people have lost a lot of
money and just finally I just wonder how
many single men now come to you because
I know that's always been a major
problem in that they are always the very
bottom of the list of being able to be
allocated any social housing right and
there's quite a few questions there so
I've probably forgotten the first one
and so I'll work my way backwards and
with regards to the number of single men
we do see a lot of single men and
and in particular homeless men and men
that have got issues with drug and
alcohol and but I don't have those
statistics with me today so I can give
you specific you know actual statistics
I can get those runoff for you and we do
we do track ages and sexes the bulk of
our clients are female but I will get
those for you with regards to Trading
Standards we work very closely with
Trading Standards and there's one
particular well there's quite a few
situations I could cite but there's one
elderly client of ours who was
continually buying things on the my
phone calls constantly being phoned up
being asked to buy stuff and because she
was lonely and vulnerable she spoke to
them and then she invited them around
and allowed them to come into her house
and they would talk to her for several
hours until eventually she said yes so
every time we did a home visit there we
noticed that there was more and more new
things being put in place and didn't
really twig until we were asked to go
there and for completes and forms for
pension credit and when we were
completing the pension credit form she
said oh but that doesn't include the
eight thousand pounds I've just spent on
the radiator and the water purification
box so basically she had purchased his
water purification box to clean water to
go into a radiator and another one a
panel to warm up the water so she would
never have to heat her water again and
so at one of our County meetings I spoke
to Trading Standards and the name of the
company that had provided those pieces
of equipment were under investigation by
Trading Standards
and using her evidence and our evidence
and some other people that had been
affected a successful prosecution was
taken of that particular company and
Trading Standards then fitted made her
Kawasaki no cold calling zone and fitted
the true core phone system so that they
would actually she could actually
monitor her phone calls coming in and
also put a sticker on the front door
which she still had somebody come but
then when they saw this the you know the
trading standard sticker on the front
door
he actually hurried out again quickly
and now because she has had a talk from
one of the Trading Standards officers
she's a little bit more aware she still
makes mistakes and she still phones us
up and says I think I've got a problem
and then we deal with it and get the
money back for her so that's one example
where we worked closely with Trading
Standards and then we've had another
client who was having some gardening
work done and the bill went up and up
and up and to a situation where there
was intimidation going on and again we
did a joint visit which rating standards
and called the police
so we also do scam awareness prevention
in the LCS we've got posters up and the
banks are quite good at referring people
to us as well so yeah there is a close
working relationship between us and
Trading Standards with regard to our
reserves we do all have reserves because
we are all companies and charities and
so we have a duty to make sure that we
are financially stable and for some
funders they look at how stable we are
and they expect us to have reserves
because they would not be comfortable
giving us grants and project funding if
they thought that we weren't going to be
here tomorrow so we do need reserves in
order to ensure that we are sustainable
but practically you can't keep setting
deficit budgets and eating into your
reserves because sooner or later the
reserves won't be there anymore and so
for us we feel it is prudent to have
reserves just as Suffolk County Council
and the District Council's and any other
organization should have savings
councillor mana Thank You chair really
this is directed obviously it Carol
being a member of the trustee board I'm
fully aware of the increased amount of
work that the local branch has to do
there's been a lot in the media
regarding help for parents with school
children during school holidays with
referrals to food banks
what sort of increase in referrals have
you noticed this summer having to refer
for the local food bank I probably
should know the answer that but I don't
know the answer to that that's probably
one of those ones who are going to come
back and let you know and we have seen a
definite increase in footfall during the
summer holidays and we are very
conscious of the fact that once children
you know can no longer have their school
dinners
that's when life gets more expensive and
everything gets a little bit more
fraught at home and then it starts with
uniforms which again is where we can we
have helped in the past access in school
uniform costs
councillor Wellum Thank You chair three
completely separate questions one is I'm
sometimes sold oh I won't go to CIB
because I as a waiting list if you could
dispel that I'd be grateful do you have
any drop-in sessions in the evenings for
people who are on Saturdays for people
who are in work and comparing your
impact between the two and I guess this
is you know it's different across the
whole country in the case of Bebo we
gain two hundred and thirty K in income
for our clients and that figures one
point four in the mid Suffolk and
managing debt the two figures are quite
different one other question no-knock
then you've got a whole lot and you're
on the edge of you're on the edge of
stuff but presumably you have clients
from places like twins did and just
across the border do you get funding
from essex thank you and starting with
the essex question they're dead there's
a bit of a difficult problem going on it
as far as I know by the local Essex and
LSE A's and their district councils I
don't think they're taking much of an
interest in their own LCAs
but having said that we do there's a
cross-border situation that goes on with
all else yeah some may come from Essex
and usually Colchester or Braintree area
to us but then equally people may go
across the border and see them rather
than us so it's it's sort of swings and
roundabouts if you like if that goes on
all over the all over the geography of
it with regards to the depths lower debt
levels we have been without a debt
specialist for a short while because
we've not had somebody in post that
would be able to do the casework so it's
dropped our figures a bit in that in
that period of time we're hoping to
resolve that in the very near future we
did have a project with Bebo that I
actually
linguist because I felt that we weren't
in a position to deliver it in the way
that we'd usually aspire to so asked him
to come to an end with that funded
project until I was in a better position
to deliver it and I feel it should be
delivered so that has kept their numbers
down a little bit and the other question
was about the waiting time sorry okay so
you asked about the drop-in and people
can drop in and be seen and we do record
our waiting times how long people have
to wait for advice and normally it is
only sort of five ten minutes before
they're saying in very rare cases it
might be an hour and if we've got a
switch over in shifts at lunchtime if
one team's finishing and the other team
haven't quite arrived for the day we do
a late night opening in to hop our six
in the evening so we can accommodate
people that need to come after work and
so we sort of addressed that issue we've
looked at doing Saturdays in in the past
most of the LCAs have opened on a
Saturday morning but one of the
challenges with opening on a Saturday
morning is that nobody else is open on a
Saturday morning so if there are issues
with council tax debt or housing debt or
any you you can't DWP you can't get hold
of anybody and so it's it's there's not
an awful lot you can do we do try and
open between Christmas and New Year
because we recognize the fact that I
mean this this year Christmas is
Wednesday I think isn't yeah Wednesday
isn't it so I think we will be open on
the Friday and possibly the Monday as
well and we talk the food bank and the
food bank normally organizes some food
parcels and we'll do deliveries for us
because we know that that estate was
saying earlier you haven't got the
school dinners you've got extra visitors
and everything else so so we're open
during Christmas to new
we went to 6:30 and then one of the
stats that I had that I didn't give you
earlier Citizens Advice has got its own
advice and information system I don't
with anybody of you have ever looked at
it in the old days people would come in
and say to us you know what is my
holiday entitlement and things like that
well we all Google everything nowadays
dope if you want to know who's married
to who or whatever you just look it up
and last year in 1819 there were 41
thousand visits in Baber
to the Citizens Advice website and there
were 45,000 visits from mid Suffolk to
the Citizens Advice website so people
can access some formative advice from
Citizens Advice 24 hours a day seven
days a week and that can start to help
them resolving their problem counselor
custom high yeah thank you very much for
the work you do it's absolutely crucial
and fantastic my question is sort of
maybe it personally we've got you were
talking about the the people that can't
afford the cup of tea when they go to
them they they go to UM social and the
groups and things like that the UM there
are a lot of people in in Suffolk that
don't ask for help it's kind of a.m.
with the older generation they they
steer clear of anyone that's offering
them help there's disabled people that
have been in the same house for years
that will never go to you or go to
anyone else for help they just they just
keep going and maybe a tweak to the
benefits or helpful in our form might
solve a lot of those problems and
personally what do you think we can do
altogether because obviously that the CA
B deals with people coming in through
the door but how do we reach out to
those people and deal with those issues
we do work very closely with other
partners in the hope of finding those
people and we do try to give as many
access options as possible as Carol's
explained through email telephone we
provide home visits where necessary a
good example of something situation that
you've just described was just a week or
two ago we're now working in a GP
surgery in Hadley and needs were careful
I'm not going to much description but
one of the GPS rang me to ask would we
be able to provide a home visit to a
patient that he was very very concerned
about for all sorts of reasons who
didn't really access services and the
whole problem one of the problems the
root of the problem was that this chat
needed so much helping in so many ways
but wasn't reaching out anywhere and we
were able to send an advisor and the
first conversation was on obviously the
client gave consent for the GP to give
us the details and the client consented
to one of our advisors visiting and the
first interview or discussion was on the
chats doorstep but it's going on from
there
and it's been a great relief to the GP
who's been at the end of these in which
to know what to do with this patient
because there was just no way that he
could send them and they weren't willing
really to make that step but between the
joint up services that we're now we're
now working in with the surgeries and it
can be with counselors it can be with
MPs it was with all sorts of partners
it's with each other that we we can
reach out and find these people because
obviously a lot of the baby district
that I cover is very rural so is you're
very right the point you've made is a
very good point it is it's something we
really do need to keep hammering away
out and this is why we also have
outreach is where possible was new
we've had referrals from the fire
service as well when they've gone out
and done smoke alarm fitting and things
like that we had a referral into the
benefits service for that but we tried
to promote the service as widely as we
can with press releases hopefully we may
be in the newspapers this month for all
this week for volunteers looking out for
volunteers and and just promoting the
service as much as we possibly can right
I think at this point I'd like to come
back if I may to come towards the
question of funding it's been a central
point of our reason to be to bring the
subject up as well as the service
provided now I have some questions from
Council a scarf who's unable to be here
today
it may in part have been answered but
please bear with me
he asks are there substantial different
types of funders particularly outside
bodies such as charities trusts etc he
believes that could be useful to know
and in in that case are they on a
service level type arrangement and if so
how many years will those be in place
but there's obviously that could have
future funding impacts so that's the
first coin that I've got something to
follow along with but yep all our
funding is provided on an annual basis
so the the funding from Suffolk County
counts so it was an annual and you know
it was announced in sort of November
that we might not get it from April and
funding from the District Council so
it's always done on an annual basis and
quite often we don't know about that
until April May June and we do have miss
Suffolk we have one project that is
funded and we sort of get a three year
agreement for that but most of the stuff
is on a
year by year basis which makes it really
really hard because although we have got
the reserves at what point do you start
really cutting back because when you're
looking at the service that we deliver
which we operate four five days a week
and we are busy four five days a week if
you are looking to reduce the service or
you're you know you've got a funnel
effect you're just going to make it even
busier on the days that you are open but
we do look at all the Trust's we use
suffer Foundation Community Foundation
who hold a lot of the local stuff and we
apply for whatever we can Citizens
Advice will do national schemes like the
help to claim which we're delivering at
the moment for universal credit but that
is only to the end of March so we don't
even know whether we have makes so
effectively yes there's no year by year
basis now that must make budgeting
rather difficult so we come back to the
central point which is the overall
funding now you mentioned earlier I
think Carol that you had some figures
for this current financial year we've
got we've got the annual reports of 1718
we haven't supply those towards the
committee to the to our to our
deliberations and to our report I think
that would be useful it can be
circulated amongst all the members of
the committee for our considering
whether we how we take this forward and
so thank you both for everything you've
provided we also have both cabinet
members from the respective two councils
Baberaham mid Stafford Derek Davis and
and Julia Blackman I apologize Julia
stir this list of names here trying to
remember who's who know and I believe
you've been discussing with officers the
impacts that the service provided by CA
B has on councils so this is after all
we are the major funders of these two
respective service bureaus could would
you like to introduce those points and
then perhaps
some questions
well firstly Thank You Caroline :
I spent a really really good morning
with Carol not so many weeks ago and
their work for us is invaluable
it really is I've been there the first
stop and if they if they're not funded
by us I see you know big problems with
housing with homelessness to be dead so
I think they just do a fantastic job and
we saw in action while we were there
what they haven't said also is you know
they do deal with perhaps some quite
violent people as well so they need
training on how to deal with those
situations mmm at the moment we fund mid
Suffolk CA B to the tune of eighty six
thousand seven hundred okay
and also Keith mentioned about cross
border we also fund dissing district
eight thousand eight hundred and ten
pounds now if you think about the vast
spread of mid Suffolk you've got people
up towards death as pale grave Giz
lingam lacks field those sort of places
Stradbroke so obviously those people
will go to dis that's why we fund those
as well that was the question that came
up with Essex so you know we and I know
as a cabinet member we have talked about
the prospect of us saying exactly what
we're going to fund you for three years
at a time which would help you so we
have brought that up and actually I
thought we agreed to that as I said to
you the other day so I will be bringing
that forward at the next meeting of what
you know if we can actually put that you
know pen to paper and say we definitely
will do that which would help you the
other thing is obviously you you know
you have been in discussion we
how you could can't countrywide get
together and perhaps come up with some
sort of business plan but I know a lot
of you work you know in your own areas
rather than a joined-up approach but is
that something that you'd be thinking
about at all why we still need to remain
independent to some extent so we look at
joint work and and promotional
opportunities together we have what we
have what we call an alliance and we we
use an action plan that we're all
putting together at the moment to try
and better the position of us as a whole
across the county but there are lots of
reasons why we need to make it we main
independent some of those reasons I've
probably got this question mark you may
all realize from what we've been telling
you today that Carol and I have very
busy jobs we are both operational and
strategic managers in our independent
LCAs sometimes you have one person doing
each job but we do both we're head cook
and bottle washer if you like that jobs
becoming busier and busier because we've
lost funding we're having to diversify
we're having to bring project money and
we're having to manage those projects we
have to monitor and report on those
projects we've also seen an increase in
the general demand as we've explained
today in Sudbury we've seen a 28%
increase in demand on our general advice
so looking at it that way what you've
got to really think about they're the
only they've been comparisons made both
LCAs have looked at whether there are
any costs to being done saved by any
sort of merger and we found there
weren't any there was more much more
negative than positive stuff it has been
looked at the main one being of course
it would be the chief officer role
manager's role that would be the one to
go and share
well and basically that wouldn't work
because they're they're larger
organizations I have currently coming in
the region of 60 volunteers to manage
apart from paid staff Carol's is not
dissimilar all those people need that
sort of management this we've got paid
supervisors but they need you there on
most days a week so all would be doing
by cutting the cost of cutting staffing
and restructuring that situation would
be put in another tier of management in
so we'd have two operational managers in
each site with some form of CEO or chief
officer having to head those on the
strategic side our volunteers they want
to work in their own local communities
they certainly don't want to travel for
the sort distances that you're talking
about between stone market and something
town centre or sort of district regions
there's the expenses of paying for them
to travel if they chose to training
would be almost impossible to deliver
across both sites in the current
situation I have was my training officer
and Carol hazard - how she manages her
we've only got nine point seven
full-time staff full time equivalent
staff between us so any sort of
restructuring there's very little room
for movement there so the answer to that
is I'm really glad to put this to rest
to be honest because it's it's an
obvious oh you know that's just a simple
thing to do but there's actually no
benefit in that and probably from what
we've seen from other mergers they've
had to be in several restructures due to
financial losses the budgets don't seem
that substantial in the first place - oh
nice what games could be fairly minimal
councillor Davis do you have anything
you want to add about these services
provided to councils yeah sure I'll try
not to repeat too much that's already
been said um but and so I'll mainly
focus on Bebo but it's it's absolutely
vital that we support the CAS you know
without a shadow of doubt
in terms of figures someone asked for
something earlier on but babe contribute
53,500 towards a revenue cost this is
from the year to March 2020 and has
funded Sabri CFO for a number of years
we also fund it we fund put towards it
which CA a total of seven thousand six
hundred seventy-three for the year so
again it's that cross-border working and
it has to be said you know without the
support of the see a baby residents
would really suffer we we as a
communities team go out and do an awful
lot in terms of health and well-being
community safety and everything like
that
but the the CAS are pretty much the
first point of contact and would also
like to mention a point I think it was
councillors and that bottom that
mentioned earlier on about some trade
Trading Standards I recently had an
occasion to for a group of my residents
to contact Trading Standards and found
that had to go through the the CAA so I
had to go through sales advice so if
Suffolk County Council are going to cut
the funding they're cutting the funding
towards Trading Standards because that's
where the budget comes from Trading
Standards so they're basically getting
that the advice and the and the work
that firsthand sort of helped from CA
they're getting that for nothing because
they're not contributing towards it and
and of course they clearly expected the
district councils and other authorities
the CCG to to fund everything that's
going on well you know when they're
making cuts in lots of other areas and I
understand that they have financial
restraints as well but when they're
making cuts to the bus services to
social care yes the districts that have
to pick up so while we would love to be
able to give the cia's even more money
you know we physically can't because
we've got our own budgets as well and
we're finding we're having to pick up
more and more of of what see over the
southern councilor are cutting um it's
clearly a difficult situation and I'm
really glad for the explanation about
not being able to merge I think that's
really useful because it's an obvious
thing to suggest that you know and we
all do this don't we
yes let's just merge it and save money
it does it doesn't always work and I'm
really happy that you please we do need
to work smart so we do need to find ways
ahead but you know I cannot emphasize
enough how important word these guys do
and I want to thank them from all of my
baby resonance okay members I'd like to
invite you to take any questions you
have to do to cabinet members on that
matter of the services that CA provide
towards supporting our own services
counselor often I'm not clear and so
maybe you could clarify how you intend
to proceed as part of your budgets and
in conjunction with Suffolk County
Council so quite frankly we don't end up
with a crisis situation like we had last
time there really I mean I think it's a
case of I'm assuming you will all be
working together to try and resolve the
problem that the CEO bees are faced the
councillor Davis if you'd like to answer
that I've also got a comment tape we
just add before we go any further that's
part of the purpose council rotten of
this scrutiny function is to avoid
exactly the situation you're just you're
describing to avoid a crisis by the time
budgets are reached the end of this year
Council Davis yeah thank you and it is
exactly that we do need to find a
solution we need to be as creative as we
possibly can be
yeah but I'm the first thing since I
would urge 7kt council to rethink their
decision and I'm glad to hear that this
talk still going on because that's at
least as taut as straw to grasp are for
us councilor Flatman mentioned we do
intend to help with the budgeting to
have a three-year revenue grants funding
not just for the CA but on a widespread
basis because we understand you know
this the year-on-year hand-to-mouth so
resistance is not great so that's
something that certainly Baber
is doing it Suffolk as well we're doing
that jointly so we are working towards
that and and I'm and I'll be really
grateful that scrutiny explores all this
and we can work together and obviously
the CCG obviously plays a big part in
this as well
and we need to encourage other funders
one of the big issues again that there's
a definite correlation between the cut
some central government that cuts from
so accounts or so the rising issues that
the CA have and lots of other groups
have and of course that's also placed a
huge strain on volunteers because
because there's less funding in paid for
organizations if you like more and more
volunteers are required across all
different sectors across the community
which makes it it's a very competitive
business getting volunteers we've seen
community action Suffolk put an out
please and and going for people but you
know it tends to be the same people if
you like doing the same ones and there's
only so many hours in today that you can
you can do that so to answer your
question in a long-winded way yes we are
looking at that but hopefully this
gritty process will help in them
Thank You councillor Davis any questions
from members
rivals thank you very much I think we're
getting to a stage now where we can
counsel Maybury did you have something
we'd like to say Thank You chairman for
in indulging me and there were just two
comments that I would like to make one I
heard I think it was Colleen talking
about professional people coming to work
at CA B and I can absolutely endorse
that having friends who have retired
from professional places and that they
are coming to you and really it's been
when you become a district councillor
it's surprising how friends come to you
and say what can I do so what I'm trying
to say to you is that
apps you need to engage more with ward
members to see what connections they
have so that's the first point the
second point I'd like to make is that
for two years I maintained the grant to
you and looking at your figures it
actually works out at 20 pounds a head
and I don't think that's bad value so
thank you Thank You councillor maverick
okay members I think the question now
for debate and discussion amongst
ourselves is where do we go forward from
here and I think that's very much up to
you so before we actually come to
forming any resolutions I just like to
hear members thoughts on what we've
heard today and what possible directions
we could go in over to you members
cancelar Osborn yes
Thank You mr. chairman well I'd tend to
agree with with Colleen and Carol we
need to actually carry on with lobbying
Suffolk County Council as their the the
biggest provider of any funds that we
can do so from that point of view I
would like to see that taken on board
carry on
thank you very much councillor often
then cap well I think my comment earlier
was exactly that I mean I think we need
to never start negotiations with
everyone concerned agree councillor
mother and councillor Caston Thank You
chair yes personally I think we should
be maintaining funding to the ca be both
in stow market and in Sudbury there'll
be an awful lot of people would suffer
if that money was stopped because where
else would they go if we didn't have the
dedicated staff that both Carol and
Colleen have
so I think we definitely must support
that they provide very good value for
money and we do not want to see follow
up with people with nowhere to go cancel
our cast oh yes totally agree I'm
surprised that the county's decision it
seems to me like this is a this is kind
of a time bomb if we if we reduce
funding into this we're going to
eventually end up in a position where we
don't we definitely don't have the
resources to to deal with the the
problems that we've got say well yeah I
I would totally agree with councillor
Osborne and a lot of other members that
we do need tea women commit to this
funding which I herewith
we are in the process of doing and in my
opinion I think maybe we even need to
increase the funding because the more
they do the more people they reach out
to the less as the District Council will
have to deal with and it's very
expensive for us to deal with it the the
CA be seem to get amazing value for
money for what they do and yeah that's
how I feel about it
I can see cabinet members head swiveling
as you suggest that okay any other
thoughts members or counselor well erm
and then counter is oh sorry
councillor Osborne other councils borne
my apologies you were head was swiveling
as well I take it yeah Thank You mr.
chairman obviously it's a cabinet member
for housing I very much appreciate the
part that our see a BiPAP play in
delivering a service to assist our
housing team it's key that they continue
to this and I can see that if funding is
reduced then some of that will impact
enormous Lee on our residents in Weber
and obviously in mid suffer so I would
absolutely hope that this committee
would say that they will continue to
lobby Suffolk County Council I have to
say I've done it in the past when we
knew they were intending to do
and I think it fell on deaf ears so I am
hopeful that with a lot of support and a
lot of sorry commitment to pushing this
forward with county that they will not
take away that fund in that valuable
funding that the CIB need Thank You
misty in fact I do recall when this
committee were examining Universal
Credit and its roll out that the impact
on our Housing Services team was quite
notable and the support of the Citizens
Advice was one of the things that was
just about enabling them to stay above
the I think it was non-virtual
quadrupling or the workload in certain
areas and we've already heard
referencing the presentation on the
universal credit right I think I was
expecting something for councillor well
erm and councillor as council Whelan
Thank You chair normally our role when
we are sort of in scrutiny is
scrutinizing our own services we look in
great depth of those services and hope
that something will come out of that so
that those who are within that service
have found a better way forward I think
that in this case we've heard a lot from
the two people who've made the
presentation and I along with others are
very grateful for the work that you've
done and and for the way that you
presented it today I think what we can
do one positive thing we can do is to
ensure that there is publicity of our
scrutinizing this service so that that
publicity can be used to urge others to
grant fund thank you very much
councillor ass does it get on and I
would like to endorse it everything
everyone else has said and particularly
over the publicity as councillor Mabry
said to publicize the fact that we need
professional people to volunteer so you
really do need and thank you again for
you do because I know from Sudbury how
much you do thank you very much but
let's hope the large numbers of people
watching us on youtube or on ketchup
will take that on board because after
all this is about being transparent they
hope that if it also increases
communication and understanding it can
do no harm in the process now I think we
have to come to some form of
recommendation or some sort of
resolution for the committee otherwise
we've been wasting our time and we want
to actually achieve positive action
we're looking to improve things
basically gain benefit and add value so
I've got some suggestions I'd like to
hear what members think about this first
thing I was saved that as the two
individual councils that these joint
scrutinies joint scrutiny committee
should suggest that both councils the
cabinet's maintain the cut at the
minimum maintain the current level of
funding versus Citizens Advice as a
minimum and what's more we should
consider three year planning for those
budgets as has been suggested by
councillor Flatman second suggestion
would be the purpose of this whole
process because we've been working on
this as you can remember from the June
meeting we were discussing a joint
scrutiny
where joint scrutiny is what we do they
were in mid Suffolk working together as
two separate sovereign councils and one
of the principles of Scruton is that it
does not have to be inward looking it
can be outward looking in this case
outward to towards the whole of Suffolk
and the suggestion always was from this
whole idea that we use the powers of
scrutiny to approach all the other
constituent authorities in Suffolk that
is both east west if switch borough and
of course Suffolk County Council and the
scrutiny committees of those councils
the relevant one for Suffolk perhaps
should be approached to form for some
with some view to forming a joint
scrutiny process across all of those
councils to work together to seek
solutions to see if there's a possible
way of making that process more open
more transparent bearing in mind there's
a minute there's a certain
at a time so it's not just a matter of
lobbying or trying to say to Suffolk do
this we can actually talk to all the
council's and see if we can actually add
value across the whole of the county
rather than taking a narrow view point
that it's only one council's
responsibility so that's the general way
I'm thinking what to members think of
that councilor I'm very happy with your
first suggestion that we recommend the
cabinet that we add a minimum keep up
with our what we're giving now and and
possibly look at a three year you know
budget sort of thing we have at least
some idea one would love the second idea
that the secondary castle Caston and
multicast infers yes the council caste
proposal or the yep bond I think we've
got we've got we've got we've got one
recommendation I think we want to full
we want to yes fine we want to form all
the recommendations but we obviously
have some agreement amongst ourselves
that the first recommendation for
continuation three year plans councilors
Davis and Flatman we just want to make
it clear that the three years already in
place yeah yeah okay the recommendation
be the continued funding okay and I
think that should provide some of the
publicity as a minimum that's fine I
don't think it does any harm even though
that's what you were thinking of anyway
really not thinking of it's okay there's
the point do any harm that counts the
customer a joint scrutiny process be
undertaken or at least we should now
here's the point we can't make anybody
do this we can contact those other
councils and we have made some
preliminary contacts already through
officers we are waiting this report will
be the report we will send if this is
your agreement what we've done today is
combined together with any figures we
have any facts we have the infographics
sheets and our own deliberations will
form the basis of a report to go to the
other scrutiny committees for them to
examine
and take up if they wish and if thank
you very much councillor Orton so we
have a proposer and seconder for their
sack that one this needs to be worded
but do you have the general idea
councillor Aires your is nodding it has
been discussed heavily in the chairs
meetings castle of Wellum
councillor Ayres can probably testify to
that and it's dependent upon those
councils wishing to take part but why
would they not it's a something of a
no-brainer in my opinion that we should
talk about these issues before they
become a serious situation let's not
make a drama at or out of a crisis let's
deal with it before it even becomes a
crisis so thank we have the first
proposal is the recommendation that
continued funding on the basis of three
years as a minimum we have proposed are
in a seconder for joint scrutiny all
those in favor so that one is passed as
a recommendation recommendation to that
the joint scrutiny process be approached
with the other constituents of councils
and subject obviously to their interest
proposed and seconded already of those
in favor fine we might have to word that
up appropriately but I hope members will
trust that Henrietta has that's properly
in hand there any further
recommendations councillor women chair
do we do we wish to go anywhere with the
suggestion from councillor Mabry that
perhaps we join with the CAS to give
some sort of joint publicity or help
them in some way towards raising the
profile to get volunteers in and perhaps
also just that might help spread the
word to other potential funders like
parish councillors take some account of
what district councils do and if the
district council scrutiny committee have
looked at the CA and said it's fit for
purpose and want to recommend it then I
think parish councils might want to go
along though how we word that as a
recommendation I don't really know or
perhaps we just refer to it and we put
it in our chairs reports to to councils
one thought that occurs to me and I've
known councillor Mabry's aching to get
in here because I can see it
leaping up and down is that I mean many
of us have got experience in parish and
town councils and we all know it's
difficult enough to get parish and town
councillors however a joint members
briefing to councillors would then feed
back to those parish councils I mean
that we are part of that communication
link
I don't know councillor Mabry if there's
any thoughts on that thank you very much
for indulging me again chairman and it's
just a point that we had a big publicity
force that said we are the leaders of
our communities and we should be showing
that and I was just trying to explain
that you have you have friends who you
know what they do but once you become a
district councillor you suddenly have
more friends for whatever reason and a
lot of them are from from the
professions and one I can think of in
particular is a barrister who actually
comes to you and they say what can we do
to help and the general and my general
idea if they don't have perhaps an
avenue a pathway that they're
particularly interested in is to go to
the Citizens Advice where they have a
broad outlook and where there are lots
of issues that that are raised daily and
that's what I was trying to get across I
think we can perhaps influence parish
councils because again those perhaps who
are on a parish council have going to
suggest a real interest in their
community and they also may be able to
give a few hours to the Citizens Advice
or they know a family member who can so
thank you you thank you casseroles borne
you want to try something yes sir Thank
You mr. chairman just just to go back on
on this funding process I have obviously
been with the Sudbury CA for
considerable amount of meetings and one
of the issues that does come out is the
funding they get
from other parishes they they they have
tried lots of areas to get the funding
where Sudbury has had included those
parishioners from those those parishes
so I would say the advertising side of
things in terms to try to get this extra
funding from I know there there's got
small precepts and are unfortunately not
able to give quite enough but some of
the residents do apply well take it at
Stowe market as well and to Sudbury so
the advertised in fact I think is a is a
big is a big must and obviously to keep
and I've gotta say this again with with
Colleen and Carol actually working on on
the side of getting the funding
continuing with subject Suffolk County
Council I think that should be kept up
as a high-profile as well thank you I
think we're coming to I'm coming to the
conclusion from everything that people
are saying is that we all concerned that
the the lessons learnt and the publicity
element is what we're really talking
about whether that be enable in order to
gain volunteers whether it be in order
to gain funding getting the information
out there which is part of the job of
scrutiny we're there to provide
information to throw light onto things
and spread the word whether it be
through here's my point the mechanism to
adopt for publicity and it's all very
well for us to say these things should
be done but unless we actually have a
clear idea what mechanism we will use
there are how many parish councils that
are currently being consulted over the
joint Local Plan 70 80 across Weber and
mid Suffolk and we all know that there
are parish councils and town councils
they have different sizes budgets and
numbers of members we also know many
parish councils that will maybe have
co-op members from time to time we know
it's not as simple as doing a catch-all
perhaps that publicity process could be
part of the joint scrutiny approach and
also the fact that we've had this
meeting we have to hope that this will
achieve some attention across the county
in the press and in the in public
through Facebook do we need a resolution
on the matter of publicity is the
question and how would you name such and
how would you phrase such a resolution
casserole chairman I would have thought
that the minutes of your meeting will
explicit and report your report I think
that's probably the case that the
attention we've given is at some length
today is sufficient to start the ball
rolling but then we should be looking to
take this forward with that some form of
joint scrutiny process should that not
emerge there is no reason why this
committee cannot continue to work with
those partners who do show winning
regardless I think that would be the
approach that I would take and I think
Keith the other chair would agree with
me there so thanks very much members for
that thank you for all the speakers and
witnesses and thank you for the length
of time you've given to this and for
other contributions as well councillor
Lavery
right just to get something settled next
item would be item 10 Jos 19 stroke 10
five-year housing land supply update
this will include the Weber five-year
housing land supply annual position
statement and also that for mid Suffolk
we have both cabinet members present for
a weber district council clive arthi and
for mid suffolk district council david
burns
thank you both counselors and for
officer representation bill appears
Bella chief planning officer Robert
Hobbs I believe what's going to be here
but doesn't appear to be he'll be here
shortly Robert Hobbs corporate manager
for strategic planning
Steven Stroud with strategic projects
and delivery manager and Matt Deakins
senior policy strategy planner few
gentlemen would like to find yourself a
place where you can hear and be heard
anywhere suits you frankly I mean you
know we're not going to stand on any
ceremony I could ask if members want a
short recess if there's any reason for
that shall we say a five-minute recess
is that sufficient time to get coffees
and other things thank you very much
you
those are all assembled I think Sony yep
cancer arises here so we're all back
together again
we're resumed with the agenda we were up
to item 10 Jos 1910 five-year housing
land supply and update the Baber and mid
Suffolk annual position statements with
cabinet members for planning councillors
Aarthi and burns respectively for the
two councils who are present here sorry
I lost you gentlemen we also have Philip
his belt chief planning officer Robert
Hobbs corporate planning manager for
strategic planning Stephen Stroud a
strategic projects and delivery manager
and map deacon the senior policy
strategy planner to address this paper
I'll then hand over to would you cabinet
members like to introduce the paper I
can if I can work it yeah of course
you're a joint meeting and we've we've
got both David and myself here the
principles for both are the same except
of course that at the moment Baber have
not been able to have a fibre in excess
of five year housing land supply and mid
Suffolk have I thought this was quite
simple for you this morning
and basically we just highlight page 11
paragraph 14 14 for Baber and paragraph
4 15 for mid Suffolk as I'm sure you're
aware we are required to identify
housing land supply and you've looked at
this in the past and of course your
concern is the periods during which we
don't have more than five years housing
land supply so what we've done is that
we've produced draft annual position
statements which I'm sure you're aware
of they've gone out to consultation and
the end date for that consultation was
Friday of last week those draft position
statements identify
as as you can see a housing land supply
for Weber five point seven eight years
and for mid Suffolk five point six one
years the one for Baber includes five
percent buffer I wasn't going to go into
any great detail and if you have any
detailed questions I was going to refer
them to the raft of experts that we have
lined up here the only thing that I was
going to add is that this is not an
ideal situation for us to be innocent as
I'm sure you were aware and one of the
main reasons for the difficult situation
that we're in is because neither counsel
has an up-to-date local plan so I would
just stress to you the importance of the
joint local plan which currently is apt
a consultation of course that has to
come back consultations considered
before we come up with a submission
draft but I would just stress to you the
importance of getting through that
process as quickly as we can because we
do need an adopted up-to-date local plan
as soon as possible thank you very much
i councillor burns anything to add
thank you
unless I'm corrected otherwise the
reason why we need a joint local plan
adopted plan it's because until that
time whatever whatever housing lands
employee figure we managed to confirm is
continuously or continually open to
challenge at the point we have a plan we
will be able to we will be able to
confirm a five-year housing land supply
and once we've got that figure it will
stick for the year is that reasonably
accurate or not yes right well I think
in that case let's hand over to the
officers and they can present the report
and they'll answer all those questions
and any others that members may have Rob
are you starting this one or is it okay
I think Thank You chair so so what we
say in the report assume cancer artheon
counselor been alluded to his
effectively we produced an annual
position statement for both Weber and
for mid Suffolk she's required by the
national policy framework and also with
the planning practice guidance and this
the change from last year's national
plan for Z framework in particular
around outline planning permissions
where we now have to enter into
statements of common ground effectively
with those promoters of those sites to
ensure that we have a robust 5-year land
supply position statement so when it
comes under scrutiny a public inquiry
for example we've got the evidence there
that ensures that he's robust and also
that we've gone through a consultation
period of four weeks to again ensure
that we get feedback from the
development sector
as to are the assumptions in the
five-year land supply position statement
I quit and we've now got some responses
back from the consultation and we'll go
through those with a view to producing
these fiber laser supply positions
Themis shortly and as cancer Aarthi from
Casa Bernabe leader T we've got a
position of five point seven eight years
paper and five point six one years
thought mid Suffolk I'm happy to take
any questions anyone has on counselor
with him Joe I was quite surprised to
hear counselor Burns say perhaps I'm
footing not quite the right words into
his math but more or less along the
lines of the five-year land supply
position statement is of little value
without a current local plan I thought
it would have a significant value
without the local plan perhaps not
obviously not the same sort of wait so
can I have a comment on that can also
have a comment on the time scale for
considering feedback from developers and
us having a firm position statement yes
if I can just clarify that point well
counselor Bowman was referring to was if
you have an up-to-date local plan you
can have your own five-year land supply
position statement effectively agreed by
the planning spectra and then it's fixed
for twelve months so therefore it can't
be challenged at public inquiry but
where we are at a moment is we still
have the five-year land supply position
it just means that public inquiry that
will be open to scrutiny but every time
that's effectively what counselor Bern
was alluding to in terms of them getting
a formal position adopted obviously we
will work through the consultation
responses as quickly as we can and I
anticipate that we should be in a
position shortly to be able to produce
the new plug-in that supply positions
yep
any other members questions cancel
rotten for at 4.4 is calculated by
comparing the anticipated supply of new
homes within the district I'm just not
clear at the moment because there has
been in the past some if you like
discussion about how the council does
actually calculate the number of new
homes projected so could I just have it
clarify exactly how the council's do do
that
robbed of you you're busier button yeah
that's right yes this is working so
apologies so the question is about how
we calculate anticipate the supplies so
we've we've got a large number of
planning permissions within the district
and so what we we look at is off of that
supply what can realistically be
deliverable within a five-year period so
are they so that comes back to the
engagement with the developers
particularly around outline permission
are they intending to build out within
the five years and we also look at what
the market conditions are and build-out
rates as detailed in the position
statement to understand yeah when when
they likely can come forward so for
example if you had a site for say 500
dwellings it's unlikely that all 500
would come fall within the five years
however an element of it's a 250
dwellings could come forward if the
build-out rate was followed by that that
developer website has full planning
permission the general assumption is
that those sites would come forward and
that's it out in in national guidance
certainly counsel problem if there any
kind of do you have any kind of leeway
because obviously a lot of that will be
subject to if you like financial and you
know the current or prospective
financial positions economic position
not just of the council but of the
country are you able to sort of factor
that in
if I can pick that up the key point is
that the process of agreeing states
coming around we developers should flush
that out and get them to confirm that
their delivery rates or their expected
timetable is credible I mean to a degree
because this is speculative I guess in
the state of the economy in the long
term one has to roll up on lie upon the
market to give you accurate information
but that information can then be relied
upon by ourselves so to that degree one
would believe that the information they
give us is credible based on their best
guess on their own financial
calculations about delivery and their
financing arrangements I mean if I could
just interject here that as I understood
it like I could be wrong that the fact
that we have in front of us is basically
a very simple summary of some aspects of
the housing position the housing land
supply position statement that is
currently out the consultation now the
methodology in there and the memoranda
of understanding existing within each of
those two council areas do describe the
sort of amount of rigor that has gone
into the process I for example know that
there's a memorandum of understanding
for a large area within my own Ward for
288 houses and the delivery plan for
that has been assessed at so much here
so much there and so much then so I mean
from that point of view we can easily we
don't necessarily have the time to go
through the rather lengthy number of
pages there are I've got the document up
at the moment but it doesn't seem to
want to tell me how many pages there are
let me have a look 46
including a housing trajectory which is
I suppose going upwards trajectory
usually implies upwards so there's a lot
of technical detail and the question is
we're not really here to discuss the
technical detail we're just here to
discuss the fact that this is where we
believe we are and this will be cake
of doing what we wanted to do which is
to be one half of the equation joint
local plan is one half five-year land
supplies the other half when you've got
both you have a more robust position
which you can defend a planning position
in in usual apply your own local
policies as opposed to the NPP F is that
a fair summary I think it's a fair
summary if for clarity having gone
through this process and adopted a final
position statement will certainly enable
us to argue that the weight to be
attached to any of those arguments
around the absence of a local plan can
be mitigated by the fact that we do have
a lens supply which is in excess of five
years so we can take comfort from that
we won't necessarily completely avoid
some of those arguments but in terms of
the case we make it appeal it's it's a
much stronger hand to to proceed from
councillor Wenham Thank You chair I
understand the position now as regards
having a five year land supply position
statement which is agreed and a joint
local plan surely if there is a five
year land supply position statement and
a current neighborhood plan that
particular parish should be in a
stronger position than one without a
neighbourhood plan and can their to be
read together
yes yes you're correct in the neighbor
plan is is part if it's a made neighbor
plan as part of the developer and to go
further than that if the neighbor plan
allocates sites even if the council was
to have a three year land supply the the
neighbor plan policies still hopeful
wait yep I don't answer your question
counselor winner I have some questions
and sent in from another member counsel
Hinton was looking at recent news
reports concerning the costs for legal
advice to local councils and he had
concerns that's the legal costs for this
might have been exercised as excessive
as been has been reported I'm not
convinced that it's necessarily the same
case but is there any cost like notice
of financial implications do show an
approximate cost and so much per site
without actually giving a total figure
and I think the total figure might be
interesting but believe the legal costs
of carrying this process out appreciate
it's a necessary process but have we got
any sort of ballpark figure aside from
our own internal legal advice from
shared legal service no we have not
sought external legal advice on on this
obviously application of the information
in this has played into appeals but they
are real costs rather than a cost
associated with this so I can't lay
hands on those as we speak today fine
thank you very much but I think that
hopefully answers those questions if
castle Hinton is watching this later on
he will properly able to hear it and
I'll send him an email in the meantime
any other questions from members
councillor Hathi um yeah just really to
reinforce what councillor Byrne said
with regard to the fact that these
position statements can be challenged I
think what I would say is that in the
period that we're in up until the local
this is the best that we can do so yes
we may be in a position of challenge and
it may be the counselor Hinton's
question that he emailed through - he
was about what the cost implications
might be of having to defend our
position at public inquiry but I think
the the simple thing to say to you is
that at this moment in time we have done
the very best we can do the consultation
ended last week those consultations are
being considered those responses and I'm
hoping that within just a matter of
weeks we will be able to actually
confirm the the position statement
that's the that's the best that we can
do in the situation that we're in so a
call again from the past this committee
did examine the very process of the five
year land supply and the methodology and
we asked for a better explanation
counselor in turn amongst those
counselors at that time making a
suggestion that we have a more robust
method a more transparent method this
one I have to say seems to me to be
pretty exhaustive and answers that
question perhaps rather more than that
he might have wished counselor Brandon
so something I'm I don't quite
understand when the joint local plan is
published this figure might have moved
by them with with changes what what
might it have moved by them with changes
in in figures that we hear from
developers and so on
so if it's better or worse does that
then link with sorry I might have I got
things completely wrong because you were
saying that it can be challenged while
we don't have a joint local plan but
when we've got the joint nature plan
that the figure is is confirmed
if the figure changes on where another
when the joint local plan is ready
I understand your question is is that it
does this figure not only hold on for a
year until we've got a joint local plan
yes I mean it does have value within
itself does it not that's the first
question and the second question is does
its value change when we actually adopt
a joint local plan that the summary so
so the process is that once you have a
joint local plan or local and that's
adopted then the following the first of
April you notify the government that you
wish to submit your annual position
statement to be considered by the
planners Bechet to be fixed for a year
and then you have to submit that by the
31st of July but because some we don't
have an up-to-date local plan we can't
go through that process so in essence we
still produce an annual statement in
line with the government guidance but it
can be challenged through public inquiry
if the developer chooses to do so
councillor Byrne you looked at what we
should look as though you wish to
clarify this well I just what I just
want to say that just because it is open
to challenge if we believe that we've
done our work correctly and then we
believe we would be robust enough to
withstand that challenge spending and
and and that therefore the figure that
we say we've got at the moment could
well hold all the way through into week
we have at your local plan because it
will always succeed that challenge
attorney tongue has challenged and as I
understand it the memoranda of
understanding a very absolutely prime
piece of evidence that we actually have
discussed this and have engaged with the
developers the people who actually
deliver the houses yes I mean from our
perspective the
sightings of common ground with
developers are arguable and beyond
questions from a point of view of
evidence in a public inquiry someone
building on that then you you end up
with a position statement as you have it
I mean clearly this provides and I think
counsel groundless question about the
future and a future change in this state
it might well feed into the
consideration of JLP and housing targets
if delivery rates are different and that
becomes a point which somebody might
wish to use as as part of their case in
adjusting our housing targets or looking
at what we deliver in the the JLP but
based on what we have
I think our perspective is that the JLP
is credibly founded and that this you
know is a is a sound piece of
information that feeds into that the
future obviously on our own but we can
only predict so far remembers I'm
conscious we spent some fair time on
this do if I refer to paragraph three
one the recommendations we are being
asked to note the contents of this
report and the draft labor and mid
Suffolk five-year housing a land supply
annual position statements which have
been subject to consultation and I think
it's important to note that thing for
members concerns this is less of a
public consultation and more of a
professional consultation that it's it's
important that it carry at be carried
out but it's as important that the
professionals the developers the land
agents and variety of other people
involved in this industry I want to call
it that have had the opportunity to look
at our five-year lands today plans to
housing land statement so do I have a
proposer for the recommendation 3.1
counselor having them seconder
councillor moolah and any other
proposals or any other considerations
all right all those in favor of the
motion that's carried unanimously thank
you very much all officers sorry for
keeping you so long whilst we gassed
away
now come to item 11 on the agenda which
is an information bulletin jos 1911 and
this information bulletin is an update
on the voids times in council housing it
was to be attended by councillor osborne
who's had to go off to a cabinet meeting
which i believe many other members we're
only eight minutes after schedules like
i hope to finish by my apologize to keep
me waiting this item was an information
bulletin on a voice performance heather
sparrow the corporate manager housing
solutions and her team have been working
on this for years two years this project
has gone on it has been something of a
success from a position of 78 days
forward to time for at least one of the
council's if not both we are now down to
as big as you see it before you in weber
a full year march april 2018 to March
2019 of 21 days for standard avoid
roulette time and for mid Suffolk 25 the
first quarter of this year shows those
figures dropping even further 213
respectively and 18 from 78 the this is
below the targets that we set and this
has been a steady process and I think
the report speaks for itself we've been
receiving that dates on this report
initially every three months now
initially every month I believe actually
and in the at the worst period and then
three months and then six and now yearly
any comments on the report first of all
or the information bulletin council
ahead of him I'm just ready to say it's
an absolute success story and I think
it's fantastic you know I remember sort
of ranting back in and needing market
about the state of it and and it's great
and let's hope it continues I know it's
also the void costs per property seems
to be under control as well it looks
like a lot but in fact this total voids
cost of a hundred thousand treat Castle
just a hundred and ten thousand for each
council
which when you consider what repairs and
the number of voids involved which is
between 40 and 50 for each council it's
incredibly good value and a lot of this
work is now being carried out or has
been carried out by they've remit
Suffolk BM BS building services our own
building services hopefully at better
use of public money and because using
outside contractors has had to be done
at one stage proved to be expensive
hopefully that was a one-off cost so the
question is we have a bulletin marked
down of the next bulletin on this
subject as being November 2019 really is
that is there any in this particular
need for such a bulletin pieces of
counsel or element yeah I don't think
there is a need because we will be able
to pick up from other sources the way
this is going I would like to propose
that we thank the officers for the work
that they've done in achieving not just
achieving the target of bettering the
target and that we do not need any
further reports back unless they unless
they feel it would be helpful to them or
[Music]
the target is not there's no longer be
able to be met I don't think we need to
hear back from every time they miss a
target for a month but if there is a
reason why there is a target being
consistently not met and we can help
with it then I think we need them to
report back well further to that so and
I will come to councilor having them is
that I note a large scale audit of the
voids process from end to end would
commence in September with the findings
in October that process is already going
to be underway does scrutiny need to be
involved counselor having them I was
just going to say maybe if we have an
information but listen maybe say once a
year just to keep a vague eye on it
I think you breathe through it out of
our you know watchlist might be a bit of
a mistake but that's my thinking um the
possibility exists of an annual one
members thoughts I think you know
there's two ways of going one we could
ask for a report in the case of an
exceptional circumstance which would
cover the same purpose as an annual
statement I mean an annual statement
automatically just you know was
something that should be monitored
anyway I don't know members thoughts
absolute chair of the performance
management statistics will show us more
regularly than that whether or not the
target is being met we will be able to
pick them up there and if we feel that
there is a need then we can we can call
for an information bullet there's one a
need for one that is an excellent point
actually counselor will them because the
quarterly performance management Katz
statistics that come to cabinet will
show the void voids is one of the key
indicators so it is highlighted already
I attend cabinet meetings of favor I'm
sure you do it mid Suffolk so there is
already a tracking process in place for
this I'm just thinking we're duplicating
and I appreciate your concern that
hopefully it's unnecessary so we thank
the entire housing team caseros born
there is also Castro's when you want to
address that as well yes I tend to agree
with counsel when I'm there however I
would I would still my main concern
looking at costs avoids putting them
back into action we need to know that
we're actually getting that that sum of
monies down with up with other
objectives to actually entice good
tenants to actually look after their
properties because when they do move out
they do tend to have a lot more work to
be done onto those some of those
properties that they if you punk if we
excuse me saying but tend to in a way
trash that property I mean I think the
question really is is that whether we
believe that housing team have got that
in hand already and in the figures here
and the voids costs do seem to show that
the vast majority of the costs are under
a thousand or one to three thousand and
as you go higher and higher up very very
few of them
the ones that seem to indicate by
trashing councillor Willem yeah I don't
think it's necessarily trashing because
I I know a number of people who have
been in the same council property for
many years and when offered new kitchen
units or whatever new central heating
systems they've said now I'm quite happy
with what I've got
don't need a new toilet I don't need a
new bathroom I don't need a new kitchen
unit and so he's bound to be like at
10,000 pound job plus every time
somebody who's been I've got a relative
who's been in the same council property
for in excess of 50 years and and apart
from doing their own decorating they've
had nothing done because they haven't
wanted it doing it's probably a bad word
to use - I didn't mean it in those in
that you know in that context because
basically what's happened within an area
that I know well is that you do get
tenants that tend to do a lot of work
unbeknown to the council and then
consequently when they have the option
of moving they leave that with works
which should not been performed by if
you like deal I want enthusiastic me
wrong I don't mean to the word trash as
such but it it tends to make mean a lot
more work for our MBS services when they
find that there's been work carried out
which they should not be undertaken yeah
point made I mean I think it was one
that one aspect of that that we can be
take some comfort in is that the new
housing tenancy agreements paralleling
the private sector make that a little
less likely and the figures here do seem
this is admittedly only for one quarter
of this year but they do show a very
clear trend towards the lower end of the
scale so we have a proposal that we need
no further report do we have a seconder
for that do we have a counter proposal
for requiring one and for a year's time
no
so those in favor of the proposal was
counselor well him second Awards
counselor mother and those in favor but
we want to make sure our thanks are
added to the housing team in all
departments involved in the voids
project throughout the course of the
last two years I think that's an
important point to make as you say it's
been a success it has involved a lot of
people okay item I'm assuming 13 nope 12
forthcoming decisions list my apologies
we briefly touched on this in discussion
in our pre meeting describes the
forthcoming key exempt and other
executive decisions to be made by the
Cabinet and Council in the course of
this council hear any thoughts or
comments on the forthcoming decisions
list counselor well um you know I don't
think there's anything there that we're
not already addressing nothing nothing
new there that we need to put onto a
work plan find in that case we move
straight on to item 13 which is I trust
ah vapors overviews and scrutiny work
plan and mid suffix overview and
scrutiny work plan 14 so 13 the Baber
overview and scrutiny work plan which
will be very closely paralleled by the
mid suffered one you will note that
quite a number of the forthcoming months
and have been filled in with items to
take us through September and October
and into November we have something
arranged now for every month bar eight
till next year
and these things have been known to move
around as reports may not be available
or circumstances may change or of course
individual items may come up be called
in and so on
any thoughts any questions on any of the
items on the Weber or the mid Suffolk
plan
counselor Elam chair can I just
I swear the members when we have we've
got one or two items very few items that
are solely for one council or the other
when we have those would members rather
have if it is possible the the separate
section there now in the case of Miss
Suffolk could be possibly than the need
of like scrutiny on the same day but at
a later time during that day or would
would you rather members and it would
the same would apply for baby items
would you rather come back on a
different day I mean it occurs to me I
mean there are increasingly few items
that are exclusively a matter for one
council or the other and it's become
apparent in the course of this year that
more often than not we are meeting as a
joint committee and actually I have no
problem with that because actually I
think it's a better committee with only
six members on each committee a pool of
12 gives us a much wider range of
viewpoints and experience and I think
that's useful in itself so I would be
happy whatever happens that the maps
wish if there was an item for either
baby or mid suffer we've got at the end
of the agenda yes I was suggesting that
if you have a single item on that agenda
for that same month maybe we can have it
at the end so that the opposite council
leaves and then the existing council
then care okay committee then carry on
if we can have a short recess hopefully
and they have got the rooms booked
longer then our meetings normally take
so hopefully that we should be able to
accommodate that it would possibly pose
a little bit of a problem if we had to
stop setting up other meetings later on
in the day for the room is tube so a
continuation process would be more
sensible after all we've dealt with two
sets of agendas minutes today no
difficulty with that it's happens if
what joint or did it happens all the
time and there's no point in duplicating
officer effort and we've saved council
time and money in that process
that's something we're all here to do
right in that case if that is item 14 as
I say the agenda the work plan is
filling out counselor often I'm on page
25 okay this is a items identified for
review but not currently timetable yeah
you've got wonder community transport
services its that purely the service run
by community transport because I think
it would be useful to expand that into
because I think that is a bit of a big
issue at the moment reason transport
issues for people living I noticed
you've got there lining is that
mainlining I hope not but that would be
under the police and crime Commissioner
no I know you mean the climate this item
is identified for the mid Suffolk
committee not so much for the Labor
Committee councillor Brandon from the
county cuts so I would quite like to
broaden the scope of that one and
perhaps bring it forward unless it's
something that you've already covered on
the previous date well you know I'd like
to recall what the thinking was
councilor well and this came from the
mid Suffolk suggestion I know it's been
looked at in the past if that has
actually sat on the topic is identified
for review for quite some time
Thank You chair yeah I envisage this
really to be not really a look at these
specific services that are currently
provided but a wider issue of more
access to services for people who live
in rural areas so it may be taking the
services out to them or being a them
being able to come in to say you know
case no market or straddle
I haven't really got my head around this
is my fault really haven't really got my
head around how broad or how narrow it
could be because it could be quite
narrow and and only look at a service
that the County Council is providing
however well or badly or it could be
such a wide a wide review that we might
be looking at too much you'll never get
anywhere so I have a feeling it's a
large subject councillor Grandin you
have any points on this thank you I I
don't know having been new to this
committee I didn't know how long that's
been sitting but I think in between
things have changed around us which now
makes this this some topic quite
important to scrutinize but but not just
the accessibility that's one part of it
I think we need to really look at the
whole community transport service issue
in in much more depth now that there's
likely or are being a lot of great cuts
we'll take a point from councillor Mabry
at the back there thank you again I was
just going to jump in there one of my
parishes is going to be severely
affected by cuts in community transport
the the link that perhaps Council of
elam is actually looking for is the
issue of rural poverty which is a hidden
poverty but it is very clear and lack of
transport links actually manifolds
itself into this rural poverty which
makes living in rural areas so much more
expensive
all right I'm aware that there are two
issues here and I think they're often
confused because there is public
transport and then there is community
transport and I'm also aware having
looked into this in the past as a ward
member and being involved in the route
withdrawal of the buzzed-about service
that used to apply on the shop become
insular has disappeared completely that
this is almost entirely in the control
of the county
council that the influence and interest
or and the budgets concerned of District
Council's do not really figure within
this area okay so the question is is
that we were to scrutinize it to what
end
could say we were punching above our
weight if I'm honest about it I think
it's dangerous to try and take on
something that frankly you are going to
be told it's not like your business and
I don't mean that was that about lack of
respect I mean that you know that there
is a role for the district council is a
role for County Council we do not get
involved in social services for example
that's not our function we do take part
in it their council rotten I'm sorry but
I misunderstood the role of skirting my
understanding is I know I'm not on it
but my understanding is that you can
scrutinize anything that affects the
residents of your district including
things like Anglian Water raw you know
which you have no counselor customer
we'll come back to that counselor
costume mmm yeah I do agree with them
counselor often it's a very serious
issue and we've got a lot of problems
gee but yeah I I do not I can't really
see our position on it I think the only
way we could scrutinize it was if we
were thinking of somehow providing some
sort of services our district council
which i think would be a very dangerous
very to go down because it's not it's
not our job but for the district council
to scrutinize the County Council I just
I can't really see where that would go
to whether whether that would be and it
considered or whether that would just be
seen as not any of our business if I
could return to the point I was going to
make is that when we were talking about
scrutinizing Citizens Advice we are
contributors to the Citizens Advice we
do have a direct stake and in fact we
are the principal contributors to that
whereas transport public transport is as
is almost completely under the control
of the county counts
and in fact the funding of it is as well
and this applies to public services as
well the the bus services that are going
to shortly potentially be withdrawn
because there are apparently being
underused because they don't take note
of the people who use free cards and
things like that we would be not just
pushing to the closed door we're pushing
it a door where it's literally been
bolted because they've already had
Studies on these to say that they are
not going to fund them we can protest
but would we be superseding the role of
the scrutiny committees on Suffolk
County Council and that ice bear is
where we might come a cropper if I'm
quite frank about it councillor Willem
Joe I think we do have a duty to the
people who live in our two districts in
terms of their health and well-being by
not being able to get anywhere and
whether that be by community transport
or by whatever means I think I think
that we there is something here that we
should be looking into and I've heard
I've heard it said that this to do with
you know the extra cost of living in the
community there are people who can
afford to get from one place to another
they don't drive a car and I just I just
think that there is something there that
we ought to we ought to be looking at
and we can help with them not my problem
has been for the last 12 months I
haven't been out to get my head around
exactly what it is to define the issue
that we need that I think we need to
scrutinize I think council rotten has
helped along that the thinking of what
it might be I need to define what it
dear me mean and what specific area of
public transport it's a big area well
and a lot of money I'm no need to define
what we're scrutinizing I'm not sure
it's public I'm not sure it's public
transport there's there's a lot of
there's a lot of voluntary organizations
that I mean just myself as a as a snow
upland good neighbor part of the role of
our good neighbors team is to is to take
people it might be from snow upland to a
dentist to the hospital in Ipswich or we
might just be down to the railway
station so they can go off to London
to see a relative it's just the fact
that there are people out in our
villages who even what though they can
afford to move themselves okay look
counselor well I think the key here and
I think this is something that we'll
have to continue discussing but the
difficulty is I would like some
suggestions from members quite seriously
suggestions and I'm sure Keith would
feel the same way how do you define with
the terms what particular aspects of it
and also what resources are available
for us to find out but we need to have
before we can add value we must first
define exactly what we are examining and
I don't think we've yet achieved that I
mean I've heard several different
versions of the same thing and I believe
I've maybe talked about something
different from what you've talked about
and I'm pretty sure each one of us has a
different meaning about this subject it
appears to me there's a lot going on
here and we have not yet pinned it down
when we've pinned it down then I think
it's worth traveling but until it's
pinned down I personally don't think it
is worth tabling until we actually have
it defined sure you're absolutely right
can I suggest that members who have
heard of dynamic here they give a bit of
thought to over the next week or so and
just email either alastair or me with
that with their suggestions and we'll be
out when we meet as chairs and vice
chairs will be will be a little bit
wiser Thank You councillor Allison thank
you sir um the one I'd like another
topic I'd like identified is the impact
on the council when patients are
discharged from hospital wheel add that
to the next chairs meeting impact from
discharge and of course that can also
bring in things like good neighbor
schemes and a variety of things so there
we see we have resources that we can
actually ask for evidence we can
actually get witnesses in but I believe
you're right counsel rotten we could do
the same with transport we just need to
define which aspects Kathryn the other
thing I'm sorry but the other thing
which I don't know whether you could
just call
repor or whatever I don't know about
other counselors but I have never had so
many emails about the problems with the
new contract for the bin collection I
don't know whether it's in just in my
neck of the woods or where but in the
last since it you know the change two
times I have had so many like I'm beyond
our beyond count I said I don't know
whether we should ask report I would say
Olive Affairs has been amazing you know
in trying to deal with the problem but I
just think there's seems to be something
wrong somewhere we agree something right
now I mean we've had surco we looked at
the new contract for surco so this
committee more than any other was well
informed in the basis of the surco bid
the new rounds is a slightly separate
issue however I believe that we have
enough of us here today
to actually ask for Olive Affairs to
produce a report on the change over to
the new rounds ready for the next
overview and scrutiny committee who must
be working on this already he'll have
his facts and figures I think we brought
quite reasonably asked that query
question we'd like a report on what
happened what went wrong and what's
being done to sort it out does that meet
with members wishes I think that's the
best way yes Wes best way of dealing
with it and I think you're absolutely
correct I know it's been frustrating and
some places have suffered more than
others but everyone suffered to some
extent at least by confusion so is that
reasonable Henriette can that be
arranged and I don't think there's any
reason why it can't be done Katherine
Ellen
yes signature and just in addition to
that I think it's not just the problem
of the rounds but the communication
between the public and the council seems
to have been a specific issue that
people have complained to me about the
sample things that cards that were sent
out showing one particular day I had
people telling me oh it's a Tuesday from
now on no it's not Tuesday for everybody
that was just an example but that
fortunately was the example they saw on
social media and everybody is
that we're all getting our bins done on
the Tuesday no we're not so that's a
good point if we can add that added in
about the communication issues Catholic
Aston could also add its it wasn't it's
not just a communication issue it's
there's still people who aren't on any
route at the moment to the stay really
um I think a day something needs to be
looked at in how we've gone about that
process of that changeover and we seem
to have left houses behind in the rooms
can I suggest that there's anything else
that we haven't discussed or covered on
the what went wrong with the bins that
you just inform Henriette and she can
ask Oliver to add it to the report okay
but we will get a report and what's more
we will expect it to be available for us
for our September meeting which
according to this agenda is going to be
held 19th of September at 9:30 there
will be a nine o'clock pre-meeting
counselor will and that lucky man will
be in the chair and oh well there we go
we'll have cake afterwards we'll try and
keep the meeting and counselor well and
I draw your attention to the red paper
which I forgot to read out of the first
I'm sure you won't let that happen to
you thank you very much members see you
some other time bye for now